pa ay c'est la terre qui est au-dessus
quoique labrecque et pas quand on
regarde regarde à gauche regarde le coib
d'habitat caméra à gauche
la belge vincent va virer autrui en
cadeaux pour ce que je fasse un flop à
londres et à isabelle je suis d'accord
les sponsors ont fait il ya toujours une
voiture qui leur ouvre la haute cette
heure-là 187 à malte en voilà
feuilleton plein fouet dans la khl ouais
on dit un trader
brad winter toi les camions ils sont en
train de le faire a plant soutien ils
sont en train de placer la terre à
l'ordre
la série patrick
oh
tous les câbles ont la dre perreault
n'adhère pas dessus et que tu vois moi
de voter les voilà c'est tout ça elle
avait quelque chose on remonte sur les
camions maintenant que la frontière
entre le camion à droite
voilà je vais jouer je peux dire là il
ya toute la ligue voilà du camion là je
vais aller dans les étangs lacs ex
points ce matin
non non j'ai tourné exprès pour toi
comme tu te fais chier j'ai tourné
exprès de patin voilà c'est pas turin
classé bon lancer à l'assaut du soleil
est super bien j'ai fait exprès pas trop
direction pourquoi tu prennes le bassin
d'emploi titre porte bien son excellent
et la cour que j'ai le plus de l'hélico
au qatar
on pourrait presque dans la rivière la
haine de soi tout d'avoir ce que tu fais
trop clairement à son pote bien dense a
su après dans sa voie là
c'est super ça c'est pour ça que comme
on peut se tourner en monte dessus
pardon ça aurait été comme un peu m
cette coulée fr en valeur votre passage
ouais je paie ce track to the screen
voilà
à l'intérieur
du gros pain avoir un c'est pour la nano
serait bonne semence secondes à l exact
contraire on se donne à ses pages plus
loin à la tu rigoles tu pleures beauce
quelqu'un kelkoo france heure-là exactes
n'ont plus pu tourner assez bon très
loin à l'arrière
justement libre au catholicisme
c'est bon laisser comme ça les camions
se croit ses superbes hausse après on
pas prendre moins de moins de moins de
matière à gauche voilà un côté super
bowl voilà il va tourner le vent est
superbe et sublime
je voulais pertes à l'heure hier soir et
vous çà et là le camion dernières agapes
posters et moi je veux dire voilà
horoscope 3 mais max ok super un faux
site élargira maman qui verra la fumée
rue de la lampe c'est bon comme ça
serait venu à un plan b
est-ce que je peux bouger un peu vers la
gauche dans une mise en oeuvre des
programmes à droite 27 contre les folies
parce que là aussi non loin de là
je reviens sur eux
ouais
alors gardons tout le temps je sais de
ce qu'on les suit donc que prendre le
train on revient sur ce point attaque
avec des puces fusion du coût de 5 voilà
long que ce soit à gauche avec de la
droite un tournoi auquel autres 2 ms
gauguin c'est bon c'est bon tu sais pas
c'est pas mal c'est important
hors pair elle joue à 3 6 1
quand tu pars comme ça j'adore
cette invasion soit peu d'ordre
hop
après quatre années votre part
c'est super beau tout ça
jean ribul dans un beau cadeau pour
isabelle tu vois de 7,7 à terre oriane
par des camions à la con que je vous
écoute et après le concert au zénith
laurent l'avis même de l'eau tu vois on
bien ce truc est devant voilà voilà
au départ la jeunesse pas pour défendre
ces magnifiques terre voilà qui clôt à
gauche
c'est un aveu qui arrive au loin tu
prends tu là
superbus et espère de plus on a ravagé
pas nicolas pereda
bon ça va on va y aller un jeune arabe
derrière qui arrive il y aurait 40
secondes et on s'en est fini là dessus
on a carrément figure pas sur les gens
nous arrêtent et joue arrêtées dont
l'effectif est en route mais la route
est là qui arrive aux pompes sont très
beaux
après la claque reçue contre la mine
derrière voilà c'est mon seul avec ses
mots voilà exactement
nous avons tout le temps les mecs
voilà avoir été super beau c'est de
finir ton plan la zone à milou je n'ai
pas super beau zinc expliquant que
quiconque du rugby
voilà la jolie marion à la route du
bruit voilà ressort à petit côté sur le
sur la route et sur le halage 130 élèves
pardon à la lavande la menthe